I think some deaths are indeed heroic
the the the person who you know steps in
front of a a gun to save on another
innocent person so many there's so many
examples of heroic deaths I think though
that both the heroic death and the
tragic death as intrinsically valuable
as they may be culturally and giving us
role models or examples that emulate the
highest of human values selflessness and
values it's all that's all there but
they also can suddenly be another way of
avoiding the reality of dying some of
even the mundane reality of dying that
is part and parcel of that this time of
life for the large majority of human
beings I think healthcare can teach us a
lot and certainly the discipline of
palliative care and palliative medicine
that I'm part of can certainly
contribute a lot not just from within
healthcare but culturally in
reintegrating this time of life within a
notion of full and healthy living I
think though that really we have not
paid enough attention to the
Anthropology of this time of life not
only across the world in different
countries and and cultures but even
within the United States and North
America in the in what we can teach one
another within our own regional cultures
and in our own faith communities and
ethnic subcultures and I think we have a
lot to teach one another
I'm not sure that they're there are any
deaths that aren't pointless in a sense
I mean I do this and as much as I value
this time of life we call dying I also
on a very personal and fundamental level
rage against the fact of death it feels
inherently meaningless frankly it I
don't understand in a in some sort of
fundamental cosmological a why it needs
to happen I just know it does happen and
that that's that's what we've been given
it's like you know why what's gravity
after all what is gravity what does that
mean and why does that happen why does
gravity have them well I don't know but
it's there and from my experience
frankly death happens I think you know
so often having practiced emergency
medicine for 15 years there are some
deaths that are so tragic and utterly
devoid of meaning in my ability to
understand anything that that all I can
do is you know remember to breathe I I
can't make sense of it you know the
two-year-old whoo-hoo a grandfather
backs over in pulling out of a driveway
or you know or the the infant who who
dies of sepsis you know at three days of
age or any number of and utterly
meaningless deaths from my perspective
I'm thankfully as a physician I'm just
there to serve and to try to comfort and
and do what I can at these point of
times
you